now health experts say that working in
an office could be as bad for you as
smoking or research of over a million
people published in the medical journal
the lancet found that sitting behind a
desk for eight hours a day increases the
risk of premature death by 60% but
scientists say this risk could be
eliminated by doing one hour of exercise
a day like taking a brisk walk or
cycling the chance of dying early was
also increased by watching TV for more
than three hours a day while snacking
researchers estimate that physical
inactivity cost the UK around 1.7
billion pounds a year and more than 50
billion pounds to the global economy in
terms of lost productivity and medical
costs that's the fires of Costa Rica's
economy and the study suggests that it's
associated with more than 5 million
deaths across the world each year with
links to heart disease diabetes dementia
as well as some cancers last year nearly
a quarter of adults and 80% of teenagers
failed to do two and a half hours of
exercise a week as recommended by the
World Health Organization if you do have
long sitting hours if you spend more
than eight hours per day sitting you may
want to increase your physical activity
to more than 30 minutes per day all the
150 minutes per week which is
recommended I think taking short breaks
if possible maybe every hour a few
minutes maybe four three four or five
minutes every hour stand up from your
desk go upstairs go and grab a cup of
coffee or something like that would be
very good for thought for those ones
worth of the office based jobs or the GP
and medical school lecturer dr. James
Gill joins us now live from Warwick very
good afternoon to you at the headlines
today all suggesting that working in an
office sitting behind a desk for eight
hours a day is worse for you than
smoking it does that come as any
surprise to you well not really this is
something that we've been aware of for
many years and I think one way of taking
what the study is saying is that your
chair is basically trying to kill you
but in regard to that they're giving you
also a way to battle through this it's
about getting out of yours and getting
out of your seat and actually using the
time that you've got
people get very worried about this this
goal of 60 minutes of activity and they
think that it's about strapping on lycra
and going for run and collapsing in a
pool of sweat afterwards what we need to
change is this view of exercise into
activity it's one of the reasons that
activity trackers sell so well these
days because people are beginning to
realize that they need to keep active
that's 60 minutes people think is very
hard to achieve because they're thinking
of it as a single block of time instead
if you try and incorporate that into
your day such as you've just heard
parking on if you're in a multi-story
car park at work parking is a higher
level and walking into work when you go
to the supermarket using the space that
is furthest from the supermarket door
rather than trying to get as as close as
possible as we usually do making sure
that you take time over lunch to
actually stand up and go and buy your
lunch rather than sitting there at the
desk
we've known these things for a while and
it's now getting that message out to say
that we can help with these things you
can do something yourself possibly the
best way of looking at it as I say your
chair is trying to kill you getting out
of your chair and doing something is
better than anything better than just
sitting there trying to increase your
activity by a small amount heading
towards that sixty percent got 60 minute
goal it's still better than doing
nothing at all and why is it so bad for
you can it do to you well another
studies shown that if you increase your
activity 60 minutes then if you have
something like diabetes your body
doesn't respond well to insulin by
increasing your activity to 60 minutes
you improve how effective that insulin
works in your body now the studies said
if you don't do activity if you're
sitting there all the while you're not
getting that reduction in insulin
resistance so you're increasing the risk
of getting fat getting diabetes having
strokes having heart attacks all of the
things that we know are associated with
insulin and exercise well yes and the
current advice I think is to do about
half an hour of brisk exercise a day at
this report suggests that we should
double that it's an awful lot that the
research is also time to think to
coincide with the Olympics coming up
when the Olympics were in London that
the big message was it would give us a
legacy that people across the country
would be inspired to take up sport
what's what's your feeling about that do
you see any evidence that people's
attitudes have changed towards exercise
and sport now I think it's very
important to differentiate between
exercise and sport lots of people now
realize that they need to be active and
that's about getting out and doing
something going for a walk simply taking
your time to get off the bus or one stop
earlier and walking into work the
Olympics have shown people the need for
that activity and people are people are
taking that on themselves they're buying
devices they're buying fitness trackers
they're buying intelligence scales
things so they can monitor their own
health and so that they can build on
what we're seeing with the Olympics the
Olympics is a great example to us of
what is possible for the human body and
what we need to do is not be frightened
by those huge goals that people set but
realize what we can do for ourselves and
that's about viewing it as activity
merely keeping active getting out of
your chair moving going to the other
side of the room to you know pick up the
photocopier empty the bins things that
get you out of your chair and we are
realizing that now in practice we're
seeing a large number of people who are
having big effects on their diabetes
with that okay dr. James Gill all good
advice for us there thanks very much
indeed